hi nice to meet you
what's up adam how are you i'm doing all
right how are you
good thank you for doing this i'm a huge
fan of the show
and you're working the show um i wanted
to ask
oscar throughout the run of the show is
very unimpressed with all of the bosses
that come through the revolving door
who do you think was his favorite boss
uh throughout that entire time at dunbar
dunder mifflin oh i
tolerate the most above um who would
have been
it's certainly not michael i don't think
i think
probably the person who left him alone
the most it's probably uh
uh maybe robert california yeah that
makes sense
happy bates her character was pretty
pretty cool she stayed in her
you know in her space yeah yeah because
oscar always knew more than them so
he just wanted them to let him keep
going as far as accounting yes i think
uh i have to ask one of the funniest
things throughout the entire run of the
show
is uh the accent you do in the murder
episode
and i'm wondering where that came from
if it just happens for the moment
it just kind of happened and you know
thinking back
it's it's kind of that kind of sound
that kind of like
you know it's kind of like towely or
i think a family guy has like an old guy
it was like a bit of a pervert or
something
or towely it's just a funny sound so i
think maybe those guys influenced him a
little bit
that was great uh one of the best things
about the show
is kind of the evolving relationship
between oscar and angela
um you know it's it's contentious uh but
it really comes to a sweet point
especially in season nine you know when
he gives her a place to stay when she's
homeless
i was wondering what that was like for
you to kind of build up that
relationship uh over the course of the
show's run
well angela and i have known each other
before the show
before we were on the show we were
friends for years and years
so we kind of already had a rapport
but in the show the characters it was
yeah it's kind of crazy because he like
stole her boyfriend away from her it's a
lot of stuff going on
stuff that wouldn't happen in real life
because it's a show
it was crazy uh i mean from your
perspective
the show is huge now it's getting an
entire junket for a launch on a
streaming service but
you know season one was a little rough
ratings-wise uh
and i was curious from your perspective
when did you know the show was great
and then when did you know that the show
was a hit when did it kind of hit you
that
okay things are working this is going to
stick around maybe the
middle of the second season but i knew
it was a great show since
when bj novak wrote diversity day for
our second episode i thought oh this is
really good
because we could really have a good show
that's when i knew it was good when i
felt comfortable i think kate and i we
got picked up for something weird like
five shelves and then we got picked up
for a full season and that's when we
quit our day jobs and we're like okay
let's we could do this awesome uh thank
you so much congratulations on
everything
sure man thank you appreciate it